well let's start with that pressure on
the government this morning labor is
calling for the conservative party chair
Nadeem zahawi to go after what he
described as a careless but not
deliberate error over unpaid tax and
reports that he had to pay a penalty and
the opposition also won an investigation
into allegations of loan guarantees
worth eight hundred thousand pounds
given to former prime minister Boris
Johnson arranged according to the Sunday
Times by the man that he appointed to
chair the BBC while both Richard Sharp
and the former prime minister deny any
claims of a conflict of interest
we can speak now to the foreign
secretary James cleverley thank you for
being on the show this morning
now the last thing that I read before I
went to bed last night was a tweet that
said thoughts and prayers to whoever is
doing the media around tomorrow were you
tempted to pull out
uh look I
um I'm the foreign Secretary of the
United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland I am the face and voice
of
um the UK on the international stage I'm
very pleased to be able to come on your
show tell you about what I've been up to
on behalf of the people of this great
country and also on behalf of our
friends and allies particularly the uh
the ukrainians who are defending
themselves so hard against Russian uh
Invasion so always always a pleasure to
join you on the show now we will talk
about Ukraine um but I'm sure you'll be
aware that we do need to start with the
serious allegations around integrity and
the government I want to start with a
story that's what we call in the
business a marmalade dropper according
to the Sunday Times in 2020 when Boris
Johnson was prime minister Richard Sharp
helped him to arrange a guarantee on an
800 000 pound loan now shortly after
Boris Johnson recommended him for the
job at BBC chairman which he then got
is that true
well I don't uh I I I I've not had a
conversation with either of those
parties uh about that about that
situation I have uh met with Richard we
uh discussed uh the World Service he
struck me as an incredibly uh competent
uh experienced thoughtful uh individual
um and I uh I can see exactly why he has
the attributes both personal and
professional to be the uh chair of the
of the BBC so uh as far as I can see his
appointment was made on those uh on
those merits
um and he has said and uh and from from
and I take this from the intro that
you've just given uh that there you know
he denies there being any uh conflict of
interest as I say I can see the uh I can
see the Merit I can see the experience
that he brings to the job
you know you say that you haven't spoken
to Boris Johnson or Richard Sharp I just
really wonder if that's good enough I
mean you're close to Boris Johnson
you've got his phone number why don't
you text him
well I'm sure you got his phone number
as well Sophie um
you're not uh well
um well look as I say the the fact of
the matter is that Richard is
undoubtedly an incredibly uh experienced
uh uh individual uh steps into this role
with
um as say both personal professional
attributes which qualify him for the job
and we've had senior people in the uh in
the BBC
um who have uh you know political
affiliations most people have uh
political affiliations a number of them
are active so it's not at all unusual to
have uh individuals in the senior levels
of the BB just to just to jump in
because the problem the the concern here
isn't because of political affiliation
the concern people have is that there is
a serious report here that Mr Sharp
helped to guarantee a loan of eight
hundred thousand pounds to a man who
then recommended him for the job and you
are saying that you don't know if it's
true or not because you haven't tried to
find out and you know it might be easy
for you to be able to come here and say
look I don't know I wasn't to do with it
but it's not great for transparency is
it
well look you're a journalist not me I
mean it's not I mean my role as foreign
secretary is as I say to be the face and
voice of this country on the world stage
on the actions of our government and on
behalf of our people
um and you know as I say I've met
Richard I've spoke with him about the
BBC World Service which of course is the
part of the BBC which is of most
directly relevance uh relevant to uh my
department the functions of my
department
um I didn't have
um and uh there's no reason why I would
have conversations with him or the Prime
Minister about this particular thing
because as I say uh anyone that looks at
his CV you can see he has a wealth of
experience with large organizations and
of course you know the uh the fact of
the matter is there are plenty of people
also say who are or have been senior
within the BBC who have a political link
so there's nothing wrong with that uh
the appointment clearly is one that
requires someone of huge experience
which it has that experience and
therefore
um you know if he says that there's
there's no conflict of interest uh I
know it's it's quite tempting to say
well hang on a second he's he's been a
donor
um that's what I'm saying I I wanna I
wanna be really clear that it's
absolutely not what I'm saying here I'm
talking about the specific allegation
that he helped to guarantee an eight
hundred thousand pound loan to the Prime
Minister who Weeks Later
recommended him for the job if that is
true
I'll say about the character in
Integrity of Boris Johnson
well as I say I don't know the details
about you're you're you're putting these
things forward I've not had the chance
to validate that I'm not pulling into
question of course
um you know the uh the Integrity of any
people involved in that reporting I just
don't know the detail of that what I do
know is that Richard steps into that job
with a huge repository of wealth uh and
experience this was appointment this was
an appointment made uh by uh um you know
my predecessor sorry the the prime
minister's predecessor but one
um but Richard does have a huge wealth
of experience and as I say it is not
unusual for senior appointments into the
BBC to be uh uh to go to people who have
um you know links with political parties
okay well this story broke uh yesterday
in the Sunday Times let's talk about
story that broke a week ago in the sun
on Sunday so hopefully you might have a
bit more information on this for us
the party chairman Nadim zahawi still of
course in cabinet we know that he made a
settlement with hmrc over his tax
Affairs how much was that settlement for
well the only information I know that is
that I know about this is the
information that he's put out in his
statement
um now you know Nadeem was a very very
successful uh entrepreneur
um he you know as as he said in this
statement
um had an outstanding settlement with
the hmrc which is now settled
um and I mean I don't I don't have any
more details than his but in his public
statement
okay so we don't know how much the
settlement was for with hmrt did he pay
a penalty
well again I don't know any more than is
in his statement
um and the hmrc uh the the words that
they used was this was uh this was an
error this was careless rather than
that's not the words hmrcs that's words
that nadum zaha we use as in his
statement
well my understanding is that that was
the that that reflects the
um the position that HMS hmrc took
towards this situation
so you say that all you know is what's
in Nadim zahawi's statement that was
made yesterday there are two pretty
critical bits of information that
weren't in the statement a how much does
that means for and B
whether he paid a penalty or not do you
not think that Nadeem zahari needs to
come out and give us these facts these
very simple facts
well I mean
we we know that Nadeem was a very
successful businessman before he came
into politics credibly uh successful
Minister particularly in his role as
vaccines Minister
um but ultimately you know people's
taxpayers in this country that you know
people's tax fairs are private matters
and I know that as politicians we uh
quite rightly are expected to have a
higher level of disclosure than perhaps
other people might do uh Nadine has
issued a statement where he has admitted
that he made a careless era that this is
now resolved with the uh Aussie
um
speculating about other people's
personal finances
um even uh and as even though I totally
understand the fact that that we are
expected to be
um I think
um you know more open than other people
in society would be in the he has been
more open than others would be he's made
the point yeah
he doesn't put this information in the
public domain it was a son on Sunday who
put this information in the public
domain and since then I'll be honest I'm
not clear you know how much the
settlement was for whether he paid a
penalty you know I'm not sure he has
been clear if we haven't been told the
simple information and also to be honest
I'm really not sure it's good enough
either you know there'll be millions of
people who will be witnessing this story
people people watching this morning as
well who you know are all struggling to
make ends meet they still pay their
taxes on time they pay the correct
amount of tax don't they have a right to
know whether a member of the government
made a settlement with hmrc how much it
was for and if he was paid a penalty
well I think what people have seen is
that Nadeem had been a very successful
uh entrepreneur and business person
because it's completely this is not
that's not the question we're not asking
about his success outside outside we're
asking about his tax Affairs and it's
still just really not clear
no I think it is relevant because it's
it's worth remembering but uh whatever
whatever tax uh um uh he was he was
required to pay was a direct byproduct
of the fact that he created a business
a successful business which employed
people uh and you know that business
would have paid tax those individuals
would have paid taxes Nadim has paid
taxes it's been a huge contributor to
the UK economy as well as being a very
very effective Minister particularly in
that incredibly difficult time where he
used his business uh experience in the
management of the vaccine roll out he
has said that an error was made but that
is now fully resolved
um and and as I say you know the fact
that this is in the uh is in the public
domain is something that you wouldn't
normally expect
um
um you know other people necessarily to
to go through but I totally recognize as
politicians we do quite legitimately
have an increased
um uh interest and focus and increased
expectation of transparency but say
nadina said that this money uh has been
uh sorry his relationship with the hmrc
has been settled in full
um and I don't know any more details
beyond what was interesting
he says that he made an error he says
that he was careless I mean you careless
if you you know Miss A self-assessment
deadline by a week you're careless if
you spill the milk when you're making a
cup of tea you're not careless if
reportedly you end up paying a million
pound penalty to hmrc are you
well there's there's process and there's
and there's uh magnitude I mean you say
that you know people do make errors
um and uh when those errors are
highlighted
um some people
try to avoid making making it right or
doing the right thing and others do the
right thing the dean's done the right
thing
um in his statement Nadeem zahari says
when I was being appointed Chancellor of
the exchequer questions were being
raised about my tax Affairs I discussed
this with the cabinet office at the time
when Nadeem zahari was Chancellor was he
under investigation by hmrc
well as I say I I don't know any more
detail about the timing about the
granularity of this fuel
we almost in uh his his statement but
the point is this is not this is not
granularity this is the question about
whether the chancellor the man who is
literally in charge of tax
igation by hmrc over his taxes and you
don't know if that's true or not I mean
that you can see how that looks right
well as I say the detail I have is the
detail that Nadine has put out in his
public statement
um and the point I've made is that this
tax was due because he was a successful
entrepreneur who grew a business from
nothing
um yeah he came to this country with
nothing as you know his his backstory uh
escaping uh a violence persecution and
possible death in Iraq coming to this
country uh with nothing
um unable to speak English and he built
a very very successful uh company uh
employing people and that is why these
uh that is why these uh um taxes were
due and ultimately he in you know uh you
know conversation with hmrc came to uh
came to the arrangement whereby those
taxes were were fully paid
um and I think that that is yeah and as
I say I can't guess and I won't
speculate about more detail than that
but the point is
um he has said that it was an error and
he is now fully up to date with the hmrc
he says that he discussed it with a
cabin office when he was made Chancellor
when was Rishi sunak aware of questions
shall we say concerns over Nadine
zahawi's tax affairs
you know the answer that question
already because I've already said I
don't know any more detail than is in
his public statement so if you're asking
me for more detail than in his public
statement I'm not able to give you that
detail I know that might be frustrating
but as I say I don't know any more about
the uh isn't it it's very convenient I
mean I'll be honest I just you know most
people would expect if you're coming out
to be the front of the government this
morning to to be aware of you know the
guy when he was Chancellor was under
investigation by hmrc when the Prime
Minister knew about these allegations
you would expect to have done that
research no
um my job is as foreign secretary as I
say the what I've done this week is is
work on behalf of the government this is
not I'm not I I'm not an investigator
I'm not an investigative journalist and
um and I'm not uh uh you know and I'm
I'm not uh it's not my
functional role to investigate my
colleagues uh tax Affairs
um my you know my desire to come on the
show this morning was because yeah I
wanted to talk about the world that the
UK uh sorry the work that the UK is
doing on the world stage the uh the
position that we're taking with regard
to the defense of Ukraine we'll we'll
talk about Ukraine we're talking about
Ukraine one final question on the deems
will he survive until prime minister's
questions on Wednesday
I knew inevitably that I would have to
speak about other uh issues as well but
there's a wide range of things that I'm
dealing with just in my portfolio and as
I say I should say I will literally talk
about Ukraine after you answer this
question Woolen deems are how we survive
until prime minister's questions
well well I mean look that's that's the
kind of question that's designed to get
a nice little uh commit
um because
um you know it's it's it's I mean what
answer am I going to say other than yes
because he's a very very effective
Minister he has been he has shown
himself to be
um uh you know very very successful
business business number four coming
into politics taking that business
experience into uh his role as a
vaccines Minister
um so you know it it it it is clear why
he has been appointed to senior
positions within the government because
he has
um demonstrated Effectiveness in both
private sector and public sector
throughout his career
okay well let's talk about Ukraine uh
shall we the story that I would have
started this interview uh on if it
hadn't been for the two allegations
about members of the cabinet now the UK
has pledged to send Challenger two tanks
to Ukraine should Germany send tanks as
well
we want to make sure that the ukrainians
Prevail we want to make sure that that
is done quickly because that is the best
way of saving as many lives as possible
the United Kingdom has been very much at
the Forefront of a supporting Ukraine
with military equipment since before The
Invasion started and we continue to do
so with the announcement of those
Challenger 2 tanks as well as a whole
range of uh other military donations of
course we continue to liaise with our
International Partners
um we we would like to see uh everybody
going as far as they can but each
country will support Ukraine in a way
that is at most appropriate to them of
course we have I have been talking on
the international stage about the
provision of armored vehicles including
tanks to Ukraine because that is what
they are telling us that they need to
defeat Russia in the east and south of
their country and that's what they're
saying is Germany as well isn't it and
it's significant because just you know
the German Leopold two tanks are seen as
a potential game changer for Ukraine
because they're easy to maintain they're
designed specifically to be effective
against Russian tanks last week on the
program I spoke to a Ukrainian MP lesia
vasilenko who basically said Germany
isn't doing enough do you think she's
right
well Germany has done a huge amount
already
um and it's worth it's you know it's
worth remembering that they come from a
very different starting point in terms
of their defense posture compared to the
uh
um and you know I have been talking with
my International counterparts about the
provision of military equipment
particularly in The Leopard 2 tank which
is an incredibly effective piece of
equipment of course I would like to see
the ukrainians
um equipped with things like Leopard 2
as well as the you know artillery
systems that have been provided by us
and by others I will keep having those
conversations with our NATO allies and
Friends uh to to facilitate the donation
of the the best military equipment uh to
Ukraine to help them defend themselves
against this um this brutal invasion now
the war in Ukraine is having a huge
impact on well every country in the
world but in particularly some of the
poorest Nations when it comes to the
rising price of food in particular and I
spoke to the president of the World Bank
uh this week we'll hear the interview a
little bit later on the program who was
concerned about the level of debt uh
that some of these poorest Nations have
and he said that the wealthy countries
should think about writing off some of
that debt do you think he's got a point
well
um the desire for the debt write-off is
something that is described
um uh regularly uh it's one of those
things that is a compelling as a
headline but they're awesome practical
uh challenges with regards to the
provision of future debt
um if
um you know if there is a belief that
that will be written off particularly
when public sector money is leveraging
in private sectors but the simple truth
is that the the global South the poorer
countries in the world are suffering
because directly because of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
um the UK we very much supported the uh
Ukrainian brain initiative which saw
Ukrainian brain exports coming out of
the Black Sea directly to some of the
poorest countries in the world indeed I
was in Northern Ethiopia which is
suffering its 50 years of failed rain to
see Ukrainian grains distributed by
world food program trucks which had been
supplied using UK Aid and development
money so we will continue to support the
um the provision of of food to the
global South who are suffering because
of Russia's as a brutal and unjustified
invasion of Ukraine okay um we are at a
time
um it's been a tough uh morning around
but you are the one from the government
fronting up answering questions on this
so we do appreciate your time thank you
thank you Sophie thank you very much